l'enfer sur roues de 1868 n'est pas un endroit
pour les hommes timides un homme doit affronter ses
démons ou être défait par eux Michael
Morse je vous suggère de faire demi-tour en
bloquant toujours le cheval le chemin de fer qu'avez-
vous fait maintenant vendre tout ce que vous avez une
valeur I '  j'attends le nouveau gouverneur
du territoire j'accuse cet homme de
meurtre c'est mon travail au gouvernement dans une
nouvelle ère eh bien ce n'est pas comme ça que nous rendons
justice à Cheyenne c'est maintenant tu es un
homme libre frère Bohannon je suis libre  pour
te quitter moi Dieu m'a mis sur terre pour
sauver ton âme c'est ma ville où est-il
si jamais il y avait une preuve que tu ne peux pas
être tué avec